[Musique]
passage était désert c'était un jour de
pluie
je suis donc passé là par hasard et je
suis entré dans un magasin qui était
tenue par une jeune dame et je me levais
le jour où votre magasin est à vendre je
l'achète elle m'a dit mais demain chez
nous dès demain chez docteur c'est comme
ça que je me suis installé galerie véro
total depuis 15 ans on sert très
remarquée et passion tu viens chez moi
dit ce qu'est ce que vous habitez dans
ce nouvel endroit c'est gros c'est
magnifique ya peu commune temps vous
tenez ce magasin de briey depuis le 20
novembre 1921
c'est pas d'aujourd'hui non les trois
équipes année vous avez toujours rendu
le même genre d'article que je relis jn
d'un côté et les jouets de l'autre
moi ça fait 45 ans mais mon père est
installée ici depuis 1909
alors on a muselé le changement de porc
sauce bien entendu je répétais au
théâtre des bouffes parisiens fleurs de
cactus et
il y avait des scènes non je n'étais pas
et je venais me balader dans l'ue dans
le passage et je devrai cet endroit
politique ça me plaisait car il y avait
une boutique tenue par une très vieille
demoiselle où il y avait en vitrine ne
me suis jamais fait toujours frappé un
collier de chien deux piles et à vieux
revolver
mais qu'est ce qu'elle peut vendre je
rentrais j'ai fait copine avec elle le
vit très amis et puis un jour ils
jouaient avant d'améliorer mais est-ce
que ça va être possible
et alors voilà l aventure j'ai acheté le
magasin comme j'avais déjà envie de
faire la brocante
c'est hier dans le temps nous étions 40
boutiques au détail en moyenne trois
vendeuses par magasin
oui maintenant c'est presque tous des
grossistes qui sont installés alors ça
va se faire un peu de mode légende paris
ne connaissent pas les passages et
c'était sympa
je pense qu'ils sont bêtes
la galerie aujourd'hui bombe c'est un
petit peu comme si vous trouviez dans un
tas de cailloux info style c'est
l'exception et ce pendant la guerre y
apparaît aujourd'hui comme un aliment
naturel
alors en fait la galerie allez viens de
l' architecture c'est un objet
architectural un objet moderne en son
temps aujourd'hui une donnée naturelle
qui appartient au paysage au même titre
que toutes les maisons de tout
l'héritage architectural des siècles
nous ont précédés
les passages couverts c'est une
innovation du début du 19e siècle en
gros on veut dire qu'ils apparaissent
tous empreints 17 190 et 10,50 apprécié
du sein je crois que ça correspond à une
l'échelle de la ville qui n'est plus du
tout la même que les chaînes actuelles
avec le pari est encore enfermés avant
1860 dans la muraille des fermiers
généraux qui correspond aux actuels
boulevards intérieurs et donc la vie est
beaucoup plus petit
elle l'a la ville actuelle à environ 6
km de rayon la ville design tient k4 est
en fait elle vit sur son espace xviie
siècle sur les murailles de louis xiv et
celles qui sont déterminés par les
portes saint denis saint martin est
certain qu'on connaît bien qui sont très
proches du centre qui sont à à peine
deux kilomètres de ras de bari alors
dans cette ville extrêmement étroites la
circulation est une circulation dense
dangereuse d'autant plus dangereuse que
ce sont des voitures à chevaux avec des
roues en fer et qu' on est
continuellement menacés soit par la
route soir le moyeu de
olaru et puis il n'ya pas de sanitaires
ya pas tout à l'égout donc les caniveaux
le servent des goûts et aux sites à la
fois une rue dangereux est sale et les
gens ont tendance à chercher un espace
où ils soient protégés physiquement des
risques et la mission aussi être
protégés du mauvais temps évidemment
celle avantages des verrières c'est de
trouver à l'abri des intempéries en
phase iv y avait tellement changé et la
rue saint denis et réanimer les
commerces et voitures
oui je crois que c'est un quartier qui
est encore au fond dans sa physionomie
médiévale bien qu'il était reconstruite
être quatre ou cinq fois depuis le
moyen-âge il a les mêmes activités les
mêmes artisanat le commerce et d'un
quartier d'une extrême densité et c'est
pour ça que les passages gens continuent
à subsister
ceux qui correspondent à un coeur de
ville dans lequel
la densité d'habitation et d'occupation
est encore absolument considérable
activités commerciales en parce qu'il
est prêt à porter vous savez dans le
passage du cap qui est extrêmement
important et tout se fait exactement
comme au moyen-age à pied on voit les
gens circulaient avec des diables avec
des ballots sur l'épaule enfin
exactement comme ils devaient circuler
il faut 13e au 14e siècle
on va
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui distingue le passage du
concert des autres je crois que c'est la
proportion de l'espace du passage le
fait qu'il soit beaucoup plus haut que
les autres passages parisiens puisqu'il
a deux étages sur le rez-de-chaussée
avec la première étage qui est
complètement vitré et qu'il utilisable
comme atelier d'artisanat les autres
passages généralement plus bas et donc
on donne une impression - monumentale
que celui-ci je crois que c'est parce
que le plus important
il me semble que le grand cerf est
beaucoup plus décoré que les autres
passages de la même époque
pourquoi ces 12 ce sont des éléments
décoratifs en fonte comme des fonds de
balco et qui sont rajoutés sur une
construction extrêmement sobre et ça a
été fait je crois à un moment où le
statut du boutis qui est en train de
changer ses doutes qui est devient
marchand devient un personnage qui
appartient à la bourgeoisie moyenne et
qui veut être représentés socialement
par une architecture de qualité un peu
supérieur à l'eshop traditionnels ou à
la boutique un médiocre qu'il découvre
son corps ok d'accord son cadre il
cherche à faire apparaître le magasin
comme un endroit luxueux
contrairement à la tradition qui veut
que le boutiquier soit économe et
présente un cadre modeste prouvant
qu'ils ne dépensent pas excessivement et
qu'il van hoecke juste prix
[Musique]
orchies
on a toujours habité au dessus de son
échoppe où au dessus de son atelier
il ya là ici simplement le développement
de la boutique a fait qu'il y à deux
niveaux les boutiques et ensuite de
niveau d'habitat dont un est dans le
passager l'autre au dessus de la
verrière les balcons rues sont vraiment
là je craque pour la décoration pour
permettre en principe la communication
des escaliers
mais dans la réalité ils servent
essentiellement à créer un espace qui
est un petit peu comme le revers du
théâtre c'est à dire on suit les seins à
trouver de données actuellement le
sentiment que l'on est dans un monde de
l'autre côté de la seine
l'originalité des passages c'est d'être
éclairée par le haut est ce que c'est
une nouveauté dans l'histoire de
l'architecturé c'est une idée qui est
très nouvelle début du 19e siècle qui
est apparu au moment de la révolution
et puis au 19e siècle se vulgarise et on
le trouve sous forme de passage
justement ce sont les premières
réalisations dans l'architecturé
ordinaire 10
[Musique]
mais pourquoi tous les passages des
groupes et sur la rive droite
je pense que ça tient la forme de paris
au début xixème siècle dire au fait que
seule la rive droite et est développé
sur le plan commercial
sur le plan bancaire et sur le plan
aussi des échanges avec l'extérieur
c'est à dire qu'il y avait les
principales têtes de ligne des moyens de
transport en commun vers la province la
galerie véro dodat ouverte en 1826
servait de raccourcis aux voyageurs
allons prendre les diligences des
messageries général rue du bouloi
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est un lieu complètement retirée il y
a très très peu de passage c'est un lieu
si vous voulez prêts destinés au
commerce et salah était peut-être dans
le dix neuvième siècle mais puis à
l'heure actuelle ce qui me séduit
lorsque je vois le passage c'est cesser
le climat on vit avec un éclairage
d'aquarium il n'y a aucun bruit l'airé
les bruits de la rue et n'être pas les
gens que l'on voit sont toujours les
mêmes les passagers les passantes de la
galerie sont toujours les mêmes
personnes qui empruntent ce passage
c'est donc vivre dans un vase clos et
c'est peut-être ce qui me saluent
particulièrement est ce que je ressens
chaque fois que
j'ouvre mes persiennes maudira chouette
je suis assagi vers automn'art et ça je
le dis tous les jours c'est
[Musique]
il faut dire que nous avons un régime un
peu particulier les grilles de la
galerie souvent le matin à 6h30 se ferme
à 10 heures le soir et à partir de ce
moment-là peut-être que les rares
personnes qui vivent qui demeure dans la
galerie véro dodat se rencontrent
parfois et alors là c'est parfois même
drôle parce que nous rencontrons entre
deux chambres en peignoir et nous
faisons la conversation sur le pas de
notre porte dans une semi obscurité
voilà puis à ce moment là on se sent
chez nous on se sent dans une sorte de
propriété qui mesure 80 mètres de long
sur 4 mètres de large et mon dieu c'est
très agréable
est ce que vous voyez qu'il ya des
traits de caractère communs aux
habitants des passages à ceux qui
choisissent d'y vivre et d'y faire
commence je le pense je pense que ce
sont des gens qui fuient j'allais dire
la nature où le soleil en fait d'autre
que je dis ça parce que c'est ces
manques âge je déteste le soleil je
déteste la verdure les arbres les petits
oiseaux tout ça ça me fait partie en
courant je crois que c'est
c'est le point commun c'est peut-être
aussi le besoin de vivre dans un lieu
clos
[Musique]
m
encore un nouveau venu s'installe dans
la grande qu'est ce qui se passe au
walhalla c'est très drôle parce qu il y
a cinq ou six personnes
je pense ne voulons pas le dire mais en
réalité ça quand ils faisant passer un
exam non salariés ce qui va faire
syllabes les plantes vertes les petits
oiseaux s'il a envie de boire le thé à 5
heures et qu'elle est sans qu'un interne
le provoquant un petit peu on sait très
gentils vous savez c'est pas du tout du
bizutage mais on a envie de savoir qui
s'installent là et c'est très drôle
nous nous trompons rarement nous avons
vu plusieurs personnes veut lire et est
assez rapidement repartir
devant nous il y avait le passage de
l'opéra vous avez certainement entendu
parler ici de passagers l'opéra avait un
intérêt avant le percement du boulevard
haussmann
car pour aller de la rue shosha à la rue
à la bourse ou la rue de richelieu
il fallait emprunter le passage des
opéras prendre le passage des princes et
venir ici blé y passer au moins cinq à
six mille personnes par jour du reste le
propriétaire nous obligeaient le soir
qu'il le passage ne former qu'un minuit
le on nous utilise est allumée nous
avions des lampes à incandescence et
nous à l'union toute la soirée jusqu'à
minuit et la parfumerie travailler
jusqu'à minuit l'heure du matin et ça
s'est arrêté en quelle année ce1 bien ça
ralentit terriblement après le passage
après le percement du boulevard espagne
est ce que vous savez que le boulevard
haussmann s'arrêter avant 28 rue fait
bout de la rue taitbout à la rue drolet
a continué le boulevard haussmann vous
avez vu qu'on est à créer des magasins
no go et ça s'est arrêté parce que le
passage de l'opéra qui existaient n'a
plus d'utilité les gens passer rue
jouffroy passeur rocha et passer par la
rue de richelieu pour aller à la bourse
notre passage est mort à peu près
commencé à mourir à cette époque là
le passage du prado relie le boulevard
saint denis à la rue du faubourg saint
martin
la jeunesse ici j'ai débuté j'avais 21
ans
voyez
alors ça venait depuis 1939 comptait
c'était comment le passage à cette
époque la très commerçante très très
commerçant nous étions ouverts tous les
jours le dimanche jour de fête jour
férié nous y ont toujours ouverts ont
commencé à 8h30 du matin et on finissait
vers 8 ans le soir
mais ici je m'aime bien ici parce qu'il
y avait de tout y avait de la chaussure
la maroquinerie y avait les vêtements il
y avait tous y aller un choix formidable
moment des comptes combattu sur deux
rangées ici les gens rentraient comme
sain et vous sortir il fallait passer de
ce côté ci on ne pouvait pas les uns
trop tôt envoyé dans un nom et puis nous
avions non petit deux portiers aussi
d'approcher les clientes à l'envoyer on
se tirait les clientes comme ça on
s'était fait toute une histoire ici ce
formidable
et
en quelle année d'après vous ça a changé
la vie des sports lui 5 6 euros
d'un seul coup comme ça les affaires
sont devenues un petit peu plus calme
est ce dû à poissons je ne sais pas
peut-être le sens interdit qui a eu six
sur le boulevard et ensuite les
vendeuses les oublis hier elle avait eu
leurs ennemis de d'abattement
nord europe 1 et maintenant elles sont
une heure non plus le temps de venir ici
avant de se promener pendant les deux
heures du repas vous reprenez elle avait
une rude mis deux heures à l'heure elle
venait à le regarder elle choisit c'est
maintenant on voit plus cette petite
clientèle
je pense qu'elle est grande surface
aussi aux alentours de paris a beaucoup
de boutiques y sont installés maintenant
dans les environs de paris il ya du
choix aussi des ce qu'il faudrait faire
pour que ça reprenne alors mon dieu il
ferait qui viennent des commerçants
détaillants
peut-être mais vous savez c'est beaucoup
de travail
penser que moi j'ai trois heures et
demie tous les matins et sid étalage
3h30 pour défaire toute ma marchandise
et 12 heures le soir pour la rentrée ça
me fait 5h05
une api journée rieng étalages alors
vous savez les gens il est maintenant du
facile et du pratique ce travail là je
crois pas vous savez c'est près du rhin
[Musique]
un passage dans ton petit chapeau gravé
à musarder
ce sont
amenez flirter
[Musique]
dis que j'aime faudra-t-il
problème pour vivre il faut que l'on
l'uc artix poète prône évolué
après la guerre à ce qu'il paraît que
c'était un passage très animée et qu'on
ne pouvait même pas circuler et que les
prix des boutiques
c'était à des prix vraiment exorbitants
que vous dites par exemple comme celle
ci à l'époque elle valait peut-être 20
ou 30 millions qui aujourd'hui avec un
million 5 vous avez une boutique l'autre
côté du passage ce qu'on voit dans le
fond les deux ouvriers qui travaillent
avec moi
nourissier les tunisiens et on essaie de
faire tourner ou même qu'est ce que vous
faites vous pour faire venir des clients
de c'est simple comme bonjour je vais
dans les bottes faire de la publicité et
palaja main des clients
mais quel est votre spécialité ma
spécialité je travaillais pour les
autres et pour les africains ces
découpes à ces jeunes assez près du
corps c'est des modèles que je crée moi
même et je pense qu'il ya pas de
problème s'ils avaient déjà qui se monte
dans le passage je pense que en espace
de quelques temps ça prendra de la
valeur
[Musique]
c
et en fera cours
hydratant et un jeu de vivre dans ce
passage brady
rado vivienne passage choiseul verrons
demain
à rodrigues vont-ils par les arts
et pas
l'artisanat
c'est pas un petit travail parce que ce
passage qui a connu son heure de gloire
avant la guerre était bourré de monde
c'était noir de monde
il l'a fait tomber du fait de la guerre
des vieillissements des commerçants il y
avait beaucoup de districts dont ils
proviennent de la guerre et en revenant
ceux qui sont venus ont délaissé vu les
frais ont laissé mourir le passage
derrière le il ya une imposition de 81
millions de travaux et pour tous les
anciens commerçants monsieur que sont
pas de sa porte le sehy leur céder son
fonds il ya un problème
bon ben je pense que si on fait renaître
ce passage du pouvoir céder son fonds
beaucoup plus facilement
qui veut tuer à payer 80 millions de
patients dans la manière c'est la ville
de paris et on a
proposé à la ville de paris de reprendre
ce passage qui deviennent passage le
public les deux passages tv il a été
refusé et la ville de paris li a imposé
c'était pour un minium pas vous refaire
la verrière dans le style à tous les
propriétaires ayant un problème social
est ce qu'il ya des personnes des
anciens commerçants ce qui va sortir et
qui n'ont pas les moyens mais
l'innovation est en principe c'est tous
les copropriétaires qui doivent payer
les quatre pays doivent payer des 80
millions
au passage
piétons calvi
va-t-on en créant des zones d'attraction
vous ne serez pas sans action famille
à mille soldats tuaient des nues
avant ces âmes passage
un voyage sans retour
rennes
accorder aux jeux ni la ville est cédée
en fera cours
amis d'antan et abus
de meyrin temps passage brady prado y
viennent ans à choisel véro dodat
raviveront qu'il par les armes et
programmes sonores
mais si on fait revivre ce passage on va
permettre aux vieux commerçant de ces
dealers font on va attirer des gens
dynamiques et on parle beaucoup des
élites et asnières au poids ancré dans
paris il en existe qui sont les passages
qui nous ont été laissés par nos aïeux
on a grâce au centre international d'art
et d'artisanat beaucoup d'artisans on
veut que ce soit un peu leur boutique
qu'ils puissent tester la fabrication
vendre recevoir directement les clients
et de là on va créer une animation
permanente
les gens vont venir ça se lit par le
bouche à oreille et quand ces passages
revivre av
on aurait il a demand et d'eau pour les
eaux et vous pensez vous aller voir le
résultat là votre fils faure depuis un
violent on en même temps je pense qu'il
faut trois ans pour arriver à quelque
chose
16 avril par les arts
et pas un cas isolé
[Musique]
on raconte aux gens qu'on va animer les
passages qu'on va animer des rup et
tonnerre ou de piétonnière ça c'est
quelque chose qui me fait terriblement
rires comment voulez vous décidez que
brusquement à thème lieu à tel endroit
on va décider du sort des gens les gens
il faut les laisser rêver et on te poser
les rêves à personne je n'y crois
absolument pas à cette chose là il se
passe un phénomène certainement dans
certains lieux passage ou ailleurs qui
émane de 2,2 du climat qui règne
je crois pas qu'on a décidé un jour
cassage hamadé près les gens allaient se
rencontrer
il se passe en sorte de dieu de deux
phénomènes le lieu playon dernier pied
et les gens se rencontrent et quand on
me dit on va animer le passage vers au
taux d'à ça me fait rire comme tout du
reste pourquoi certaines personnes
viennent
dans ce lieu c'est tout simplement parce
qu'il découvre quelque chose qui n'est
pas ailleurs et si brusquement ont
décidé de faire passer tous les jours
250 personnes ou ce sens pas que les
peuvent passer de jean larrieu de
l'environnement passe 80 pages
est ce que le passage a toujours sa
fonction de passage de lieux pourraient
bien sûr disons que les desservir enfin
et dessert exactement deux stations de
métro
d'un côté 4 septembre où l'autre côté
les pyramides en plus ça fait un lieu de
passage pour les banques
vous avez la banque de paris des pays
bas d'un côté vous avez le crédit
lyonnais vous avez également le
restaurant de la banque de france
toutes ces personnes qui viennent
déjeuner là et qui repartent à la banque
de france après déjeuner faire redécorer
des petits-champs coupe par le passage
toutes les personnes qui viennent
déjeuner si vous voulez à la banque de
france un exquis l'ancien terrain des
italiens le premier opéra didon et bien
des jeunes et puis ensuite faire un tour
dans le perçage et volume traduisant la
banque ça ces personnes à son client
dans ce message
on voit beaucoup de boutiques se
moderniser dans la galerie ah oui on a
quand même quelques unes
et la vôtre elle est restée intacte de
rails elle restera comme ça tant que j'y
serai vous n'avez pas les boutiques
modèle non je pense que je ne pourrai
rien mettre dedans alors comme j'aime
apple de bazar le fouillis prenez je
suis amer à la fête la lune et on fait
tout ce qu'on fait oui entre beaucoup de
choses savez celui qui vient et qui
n'achètent pas c'est parce qu'il n'est
pas décidée 1
malheureusement personne n'a le droit de
rien dire n'importe quel propriétaire
d'une arcade du passage à droit de la
vendre n'importe qui et de faire
n'importe quel devanture n'importe quel
est le passage est classé depuis très
peu de temps et avant alors c'était
c'était vraiment catastrophique
maintenant les dégâts sont un peu
minimisé
est ce que les intérêts des design sont
pas les mêmes pour tout le monde bah ça
dépend ça dépend des goûts de chacun
vous il y en a qui croque leur intérêt
c'est de faire quelque chose de très
laid de trégueux l'arrêt de très
attirants et y en a d'autres qui savent
reconnaître le charme et la beauté du
passager qui comprennent 10 entre les
mains quelques jeux
à préserver est ce que vous avez déjà
essayé de d'influer sur le l'histoire
oui j'en ai dix corps du passage on a
enfin on a réussi à chaque fois qu'il ya
des travaux prévus il ya des réunions
des copropriétaires et on a réussi tout
de même par exemple empêcher
l'électricité au néon a empêché
certaines choses qui aurait été vraiment
la fin du passage le chauffage aux
infrarouges et enfin des choses
abominables qu'ils avaient l'intention
de faire depuis 1826 date de sa création
ans rien n'a été fait on vous trouvez là
en présence des peintures originales du
sol tel qui a été fait et de la
décoration telle qu'elle a été conçue
petit à petit ça va être fait mais cela
est très très très onéreuses sont des
copropriétaires qui doivent assumer les
frais car le passage est classée à
l'inventaire supplémentaire donc l'état
n'intervienne pas dans l'entretien du
lieu et les locataires et les
propriétaires ne peuvent pas arriver à
payer tout ça mais peut-être vous savez
que cet état petit peu délabré c'est
peut-être son charme
on a continuellement la sensation que
l'on vit dans un lieu qui est mourant
mais qui n'est pas encore mort on peut
dire à l'extrême que si l'image la ville
renvoie à l'image du corps la ville
haussmannienne puis la ville rénové est
une ville schizophrénique poupée éclaté
et que le passage à sa manière en
permettant de faire communiquer la rue
avec l'inutile réunifie ce corps parce
que l'inutile c'est précisément au plan
psychologique
l'inconscient c'est à dire ce complément
urbain qui lorsqu on ne le voit pas nous
manque mais lorsque l'on sait qu'ils
existent même si nous n'y allons pas
nous réconforte
nous rassurons nous réconcilie avec new
man u
[Musique]